you guys are probably familiar with
Jessica Tarlov on Fox news she's the one
liberal host
um on the five and she just does a
really good job of effectively knocking
down a lot of these right wing talking
points in real time as they're being
spewed on the five by the other hosts
and I have an example of that uh for you
here in relation to Hunter Biden and uh
producer Pat on yesterday's show talked
about how Hunter Biden is expected to
plead guilty to two misdemeanor charges
in relation to not paying his taxes he
has since but he did it for a time there
for two years and he's pleading guilty
to those charges misdemeanors and then
we'll have a felony charge in relation
to lying on a form about getting a
firearm
um even though he was addicted to a
controlled substance he said that he
wasn't and that allowed him to get that
firearm and so that felony charge is
going to be dismissed if he falls
through with certain guidelines and of
course you can expect and I think
producer Pat predicted this yesterday
the right wing has been saying this is a
big uh example of the two-tier justice
system it's a sweetheart deal and he's
being treated with kid gloves because
he's Hunter Biden and see this is this
is what we've been saying but in reality
it's not an example of that it's not an
example of Hunter Biden getting
preferential treatment as Jessica Tarlov
will point out very nicely I will note
these charges and the investigation
didn't uncover or doesn't have to do
with all these accusations we've heard
from the right wing so that's part of
the reason why they're really unhappy
and want this to be an example of the
two-tier justice system
yeah I could
trickling out since Saturday which was
the first official campaign event and
then Hunter was going to be a major
talking point on the campaign and that
is slowly going away but for good reason
so to try to tackle all the points that
everybody made which were aplenty so
what Hunter is not guilty of is being a
republican but there's a republican very
closely allied with Trump named Roger
Stone who did worse than Hunter Biden so
he activated two million dollars not 1.2
million two million dollars and guess
what happened he was allowed to pay it
back and he wasn't even criminally
charged Hunter Biden criminally in
charge could face probation Roger Stone
top guy to Donald Trump
skates free on that it seems didn't they
rate his house yeah I was just going to
say isn't he the guy
no you you say guns are blazing about
everyone just because someone is
carrying a gun no one shot up any houses
no one was forced out of their house
they tipped off CNN though
the huge crime of having CNN there okay
but I love the fact that you like guns
now
I I really don't and actually I think
that there should be stricter gun
control in this country but if you look
at the doj records about how often what
Hunter Biden did is actually charged
it's basically nil 200. that's a Lil
Wayne
do you notice I didn't interrupt a
single person on the panel so just give
me a sign I'm so sorry in 2019 there
were 290k 98 cases brought of people
falsifying their gun application records
out of 27 million background checks that
were completed that's the year that
Hunter Biden got that weapon that means
that this is something that doesn't get
charged if you want to say to the doj
you should be charging on this go ahead
and do that but there's no reason that
Hunter absolutely
so number one just surface level thing
if you're a viewer of Fox News and you
see that
don't you think that
I mean just the the way the style in
which they present information the
difference between just the Qatar love
and the other hosts and how they're
jumping in like children well what about
this oh you like guns now and not
actually making serious points while
she's calmly presenting actual uh facts
just the aesthetic seems clear separate
from the substance of the points that
are also clearly better
um to be
a much more
um of depth presentation of the facts
but on the substance of what she's
talking about it's important that we go
one by one so that later on as they list
off all the reasons they think there's a
two-tier justice system we can reference
all the different debunkings that have
been done by us as well uh me David
Pacman whoever it might be because as
this narrative gets built
it becomes all these examples that on
their own as we'll talk about here as we
are currently aren't actually examples
of the two-tier justice system but
people don't hear that and so they get a
bunch of examples see Hunter Biden got
this deal and it's a sweetheart deal
just believe us but we're not providing
evidence of that
or the FBI I did this thing and that
thing that we're not really providing
evidence for and so the people have a
collection of examples in their heads
and they think oh my gosh surely even if
I hear one thing get knocked down here
and there surely there is this two-tier
justice system that hurts Republicans
and benefits Democrats because of all
these examples I've been hearing when in
reality if we go one by one
they don't hold water they're not
examples of uh Biden weaponizing the
government against conservatives or to
benefit his son or to benefit Democrats
it's just not something
um that's happening and it's really
unfortunate so many people are buying
into that I went to the Miami arrest of
trump as many of you guys saw and talked
to a lot of trump supporters as they
were really unhappy and I would ask them
okay so you read the indictment and you
think that the evidence is is not real
or do you think that the law doesn't
apply here or why do you think this is
so horrible that Trump is being held
accountable and
I think every person said well I haven't
read the indictment or I haven't read
the whole indictment most of them just
said I haven't even seen the indictment
so then how could you possibly know that
this is an example of trump being
politically persecuted and then it would
be well what about Hillary well what
about Hunter Biden and as we're trying
to do with this example and you can do
with those individual ones if you dive
into the specifics you understand why oh
that's not an example of
unfair treatment that's an example of
that being a different case with
different facts that was investigated
and yielded different results not
because of a bias but because of
different facts sometimes lead
investigators to different conclusions
and that's perfectly
um Fair
but now this view that anything done to
a republican a conservative that is
prominent
and is an example in reality of them
being held accountable for the
violations of the law in the case of
trump of course Very prominently
actually just fits into the world view
that's already been created for so many
people that conservatives are being
persecuted one more
um example of this being fact checked
real quick obviously you're already
hearing a lot of shouting oh sweetheart
deal oh this oh that none of us really
knows the details of the possible
charges here and exactly what was agreed
to as part of this plea Jennifer but how
do how does one assess whether this is
the type of deal that a normal person
not a President's child would get in
this circumstance so you would look to
other similar cases right so on the gun
form charge it's very very standard for
someone in this situation who lies on
the form because they're an addict the
gun is long gone apparently only had it
for a couple of weeks it's very standard
in these circumstances for this
diversion to occur and to to wipe out
the charges assuming he successfully
completes it so that's totally standard
and the tax fraud is is similar as well
I mean he paid those taxes back a long
time ago that's something that doj takes
very very seriously when negotiating
these deals and I'll also say that
Hunter Biden was an addict at the time
and so there was discussion of this back
when this investigation got going when
you're talking about a drug addict you
have to think about whether you can
prove the men's Riot this goes to trial
is he going to be able to undercut their
case about whether he knowingly and
willfully didn't pay his taxes so given
all of that and given similar cases with
tax fraud this is not a sweetheart deal
it's a deal I think it's a good deal for
Hunter Biden in that he will stay out of
prison and end up with only two
misdemeanors on his right
so facts matter and if you look at the
facts of this case it doesn't fall
within the narrative that they're trying
to build day after day
thank you all so much for watching
Today's Show again you can find me at
Luke Beasley on YouTube and if you
remember I'll see you on the bonus show
I've had such trouble finding a great
razor where I am not cutting myself or
getting those Nicks on my skin which are
so common with the cheap disposable
razors you have to meet our sponsor
Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below